it's name ya feelin cuz I saw your
Instagram feelin this can be an hour
podcast on what famous place drop any
names and that that's not the kind of
guy I am
what do you what are you even talking
about nah but I want to make this clear
what you have one day to tell me about
this party would it one day not tomorrow
what party Thursday Friday Saturday son
I went to watch the fights you mean that
one you know with your good friend who
spelled your name wrong yeah yeah yeah
really good friend and out-build now
that picture right there was when I said
to his daughter I said just take a
picture really quickly while he's
looking I want to stick my head up cuz
there are three legends on the [ __ ]
couch whoa whoa dude four legends the
man on the right will take you to
flavortown love that guy love guy fury
he's one of us he's a silly goose hmm
he's uh he made some Wagyu beef knock
your dick in dessert I bet made some
crazy pasta some crab pasta to you
flavortown baby taking a flavortown it's
gonna hit your mouth a key to flavortown
and he'll die the [ __ ] out you're here
he'll dye your hair he'll may hate his
look now he can cook he was cooking for
you guys he had he had the Sloane girls
in the kitchen helping him out those
daughters that's correct they were
working hard only thing I get me to that
party well there was no testosterone in
that room at all you got frank grillo
joe carnahan you got you got the great
one Sugar Ray Leonard you got semesters
from long drive here and no test drive
and little are on the back also there's
a ton of testosterone in that whole room
yeah now Delia calls himself a baby in
this picture he is a baby he's a baby
he's probably the youngest by 20 years
Julie and I are the only guys in there
to fly commercially who's the chick on
the right she is a friend of somebody
there she's a she's a personal trainer
oh god she's a physical therapist that's
cool really cool and then who's the guy
in the back who doesn't know he works
with guy fury he's the he's the he's the
flavortown assist
he's the flavortown assistant do you
take me to flavortown I've taken a
flavor shot told told that Wow - Jay
Glazer my height was very very tight
shirt you what you're not seeing there's
Michael Strahan my new favorite person
did he not want his picture taken now he
was in he was sitting closer to I love
Michael that's my favorite person maybe
now it's my new best friend stay here
me Austrian I would replace you
Australian you know and you should now
now Sugar Ray I said would you how do
you eat Sugar Ray looks at me and goes
he goes well how do you how do you stay
in shape you know and I go you know I
didn't it I just try not to eat too much
and all that I go how do you do it he
goes I'm vain
but I'm genetics to for it my the
highlight was when I'm we're all there
waiting in line to eat food and Al
Pacino is there and my friend Al Pacino
now cuz I've met him twice his friends
my friend she asked if he's gonna do a
Sherman - well here's what I looked at I
meant crystal he was there and so I did
it for Chris and I go out look at him
and I go by the way saw the Irishman you
were good you were very good
what'd he say and he started laughing I
go I have notes but I mean yeah of
course Italy it goes
get the [ __ ] out of here Brian yeah and
daliyah the real is when you're around
all those legends - Lila commanding us
he be he was like hi I avoid us hi I got
I got all his feelings in my chest right
now I don't know I don't know do you
know what to do it's all these famous
people you know it's a little real most
famous he comes up to me Chris comes as
we're sitting down for the fight and
there's Horrell I'm sitting where Chris
is sitting and he walks by me and he
goes like this he goes hey if this place
blew up you wouldn't even be mentioned I
think because you'd be it Stallone and
Friends you'd be in frame friends that's
who you'd be in France that one heart is
so funny men 100% [ __ ] Pacino still
got a head set a hair on them that's got
a set of hair and he's he's the sweetest
man in the world everybody seems to want
to fight over him I bet you know
everybody wants to be around it don't
you wrong you there's some legends in
there but the guy if you had to pick one
yeah
jeez well what you didn't see was David
Blaine who came in a little later and
sat down next to Al and we were all
around the table and everybody has their
cameras out and he did some card tricks
you know now all all you guys over 50
are posted on the gram that's that's
right it's pretty sad now listen I'm
tired so I didn't bring my phone in this
that's not me I didn't bring my phone in
really I didn't take one picture I never
bring my phone in that house just still
I'll make you leave your phone now huh
No everybody's got their phone out I
never bring my phone and I will never
take a picture that's his daughter who
took that picture she took a bunch of
pictures and sent them to me so I posted
them but I had to remember I mean yeah
slide one and the other ones 23 and the
other ones 18 yeah now you don't talk
about his daughters well you know talk
about his daughters but they are all
single and they're all beautiful and
they're all really cool flavortown man
I'm not even allowed to I'm not even
allowed to I'm 52 so I know you not for
me nobody Stan but good girls good girls
I said to him biggest accomplishment is
your daughters because that the grump is
Hollywood royalty
yeah and somehow they're all yeah they
brought me but I like where your head's
at rocky read me read me the first page
of a script on rocky I I got on video I
saw other way blah blah blah what I what
I really think is interesting about all
of this is that that might be the end of
the movie star era I don't know if we're
gonna have movie stars the way we did in
the 80s and 90s
I'm sure mm I don't know things are
changing so quickly
David Blaine David Blaine did some magic
for us that would make you question the
laws of physics and make you question
whether or not he's actually magic I bet
I mean literally he did this trick where
he had I can't even go yeah I'm gonna
have him to this trick away it was so
crazy it was so crazy in front of us
there's no way to tell is he wearing
black New Balance he did he did one
trick where I went I looked at him and I
go like cuz I've known him 30 years ago
how the [ __ ] goes at you guys it took me
12 years to make that work that took it
literally where where he did the chicken
Lou and guy Fury goes all he did is he
just looked at me when Lucifer that's
all there's it was the craziest [ __ ] in
the world did is David still doing shows
around Vegas he's getting ready for a
large but is it in Vegas or you know
it's gonna be the TV thing yeah you hold
his breath like inside an octopus it's
gonna be kind of insane it's gonna be
kinda tell you what it is uh yeah yeah
you say but when he I see a weird that
him and
elder brother look exactly the same not
yet but we're gonna tell him that
because I want to get him on the podcast
he's in town so where's he live
full-time New York Paris to would see
now but he'd CJ needs to get a little
thinner Janie's gonna die cuz David
Blaine's get a little skinny now yeah
playing gut yeah that's all Jay would
look yeah he's a better hairline though
than Jay what's he signing them
he's signing our guys decks of cards for
magicians he's a stud man yeah special
dude very special knows magic knows
magic now now the interesting thing
about being watching fights with a lot
of actors and people is that there are a
lot of opinions thrown around
I can't watch right now and I love you
yes I want to kill you yes now now but
at least I have a lot of respect for
anybody in the ring right for sure I
still can't do it yeah this i watch
fights on my own right I know that's my
feelings yeah well I'm a bottom my box
now yeah right yep and I do jiu-jitsu
with you can Machado yeah right yeah
right sure these are my rain boots
don't look at my rain boots why are you
in long white this is their minds I'm
from the set I gotta run I gotta go I go
back to do some acting 30 hilarious yeah
now imagine if so you guys watching the
fight to critiquing Anthony Joshua again
I mean not me a lot of a lot tell you
what was going around guys who's won a
gold medal in the Olympics ding box and
he's gonna Boston Caesar by Klitschko
came back and won and no no we know yeah
we know no yeah we'll check changed his
imagine if Styles watching Irish man
gone oh God Betina just you're off man
yeah I would approach it like people do
that all time soon huh worse is fighting
because what you want can I throw out
just some of the comments I guess Bruin
my day please he's on his bike he's not
even fighting him sell his bike this
guy's not a fighter he's not a good fire
he's not a good fighter stand he's all
hype standard this is bad stuff what's
he doing he's not even touching him I'm
getting that she's I'm watching any
where is this head it's the same son
passing away comments you see on Twitter
and
the grin yeah he's on his bike smelled
funny you know wasn't saying that you
know wasn't I would have submitted
rising to it's gonna be a surprise same
Sugar Ray that beat that be correct so
after the fight everybody's screaming
[ __ ] that was a [ __ ] boring
thigh it's not he didn't he didn't fight
him at this hotel I'm not gonna say who
he was saying what some people were
quiet good stuff then then me David
Blaine Chris D'Elia
what did flavortown make them oh he made
a sausage and like clams right yeah then
he made this insane pasta this white
truffle pasta man you know to buy
truffles ooh and then he may like this
crab this tomato crab like fusilli that
was unbelievable dude flavortown
welcome dude and then to say did he
serve it and go welcome to flavortown
he didn't say flavortown but he's you
know after setting the trip I didn't
know that
I didn't know favorite though but he's a
great dude he said just I've he just had
a bro and loves he's just like he's so
confident his food to he goes you ready
for the Wagyu beef that I've been
simmering I've been roasting for two
hours at this [ __ ] yeah and then he cut
that [ __ ] with this with six different
mushrooms on it I was like well this kid
this dude's a beast if fun gotta get on
the podcast actually he's in know Cal
but he's a great guy I love I just
sticks with the hair in the and they go
teach it's like welcome to flavortown
have you seen him without it no he looks
so different with a regular gray hair no
there's a photo of him before he started
bleaching into like a character so he
sticks way yeah cuz he's no definitely
his long yeah now I want to do I want to
do two things and I want you to bring it
up holy [ __ ] Wow yeah I don't want to go
to that flavortown but what I like to
see I like the Wow
damn good for him for getting a gimmick
man smart dude oh yeah didn't cook his
ass off yeah great personality too
yeah I mean that's what really chefs are
a guy like him
yeah just believes in this product too
that's cool he cooked for you guys yep
and then and then then I I said this I
really meant this to look
to me and like like puppy dogs like beta
males me playing D'Elia
and Grillo are following Stallone around
his house as he's showing us his
paintings his paint hey I hope we can
paint and he sells them for impossible
amount of money but when you see it you
go like it's so good that you really
don't to be a kiss-ass I'm already
kissing his ass right so you don't to be
like Helaman that's amazing right but
they were so good like all of us like
all of us were like kids I say if you
ever study painting is no no I go you
just artist yeah he's an artist he's
just nervous right but you don't think
of that you don't think of Stallone as
an artist that that way until you see it
did such manly
genius yeah and then I looked at Frank
Grillo for real and I was like hey I'm a
loser man I gotta get it together I need
to be more still yeah I feel like I feel
like a loser like I'm like oh job is you
flavortown you paid to I don't know I
would imagine he's creative dude to go
to Rambo 3 horse scene horse scene Rambo
3 horse scene the horses YouTube I'm
just mentioned this because I'm schooled
I had to have a I had to have a fight
with my with my jeans trying to get my
pants off I'd have a fight with my pants
don't ask it'll come out in the day but
I'm wearing pants and I have to get them
on I did 50 takes of that now it's gonna
sound silly but I was sore from that I
was sore I bet a lot going on yeah and
then I asked Stallone if he had any
injuries and he showed me all the
various back operation about his diet
like back then the first blood so now he
eats more way more vegetables than he
does meat back then he was a protein
dude he was yeah look at his body here
and he's again really riding this horse
in Afghanistan who's in Afghanistan
he says now he eats mainly vegetables
yeah but I want you to check out the
stuff that he actually really did it was
this is he did they had real Afghanistan
these guys actually played this game
where they take a goat head or they take
a goat and you have to put it in the
circle you're allowed to whip each other
your lies that horses die so there's the
goat now why is that go to live yes now
this is really this is all real he's
doing all of this he's riding cuz he's
in the next
horseback riders oh it's a dead goat
yeah and I take a dead goat an ant and
and it's a 300 I think it's a 300 yard
field and you have to each team has to
put it get the goat and they fight they
bite they they whip each other they take
the goat how this is a term I didn't
come up with it's kids we thought we'd
call it smear the queer well but you see
the horses they're the winner we're
really psyched smear that go yeah
horses fall people die it's a nutty
nutty but he's really riding with these
guys does he write Rambo's - yes he did
did he say as bad injuries be oh god we
won't be back in fact his shoulders oh
you can't I'll make it can you show this
part can you shut up nothing so he
really fell off this Joey movie he fell
off the horse in the say like this again
fans will be honest watches be they
won't know it'll be tiny chopped away we
can probably show this part watch that
this is the whole this is the stun I
want to show you how long is this Jim so
in two minutes
that's almost you're gonna see watch
it's now or anyways it
[Music]
that's him dude that's him it's not he
seated - you see the figure is so bad no
hardly there's no definitely hard trick
but that's a little hard to do look at
that why'd they do that everything was
all real I know that yeah yeah man he's
a badass he said he only eats vegetables
these days now he eats meat he was led
mainly vegetable but he tries to cut
down now he's he's older he finds a like
fish and vegetables is the best way to
do this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]